okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest i have rich cooper
from entrepreneurs in cars how are you
today rich doing good thanks how you
doing
i'm good um so tell me to start how when
did you start your youtube channel
yeah and actually before we get started
if you don't mind i'm just gonna take a
stroll i've got a few things to do so
i'm gonna turn off the video and put the
phone in my pocket we can do this while
i'm walking oh yeah no problem yeah okay
cool let me just do that
okay i'm off there we go can you still
hear me okay yeah i can hear you
all right so sorry the question again
was how did i get started
yes
how did i get started um i got started
just after a retreat i was on with some
friends from
entrepreneurs org in toronto and uh
didn't really like what i was doing with
my business
and saw this youtube thing getting some
steam
so i figured it was uh
just an idea that i wanted to pursue
just mashing up two passions which was
entrepreneurship and cars fast cars more
specifically
the original idea was to interview
uh
i guess entrepreneurs and their success
rights
and uh
i ran out of friends with cool cars real
quick so i started talking about a few
other things and one day a guy said to
me uh
you should do a video on the kind of
women not to date
so that's when i kind of started talking
about some of those ideas and it kind of
took off and i discovered things like
the red pill
um yeah it's interesting because when i
look at your channel when i look at like
the most popular videos they're actually
like pretty much all about women
um what was the first video that took
off on your channel
um
it was it was the one that i described
where they said uh do a video on the
women not to date
and um that was that was before i read
the rational mail or anything else are
you getting wind noise outside by the
way
uh slightly but nothing too bad all
right let me know if it gets bad
um yeah that was the one and i just
basically shared my own personal
experience and that seemed a
favor in the algorithms and people got a
lot of value from it and then that's
when i kind of started getting
introduced to
other guys that got some value from
picking up on you know some of these red
pill concepts as well and what was your
personal experience were you married
before
yeah um mary divorced got divorced
around 39ish i think it was
um
you know and just been enjoying life uh
as it is since
okay
and uh
so what did you say in that video like
what are the top women to avoid
oh we're going back a ways now i'm
trying you're gonna you're gonna have to
get me to jog my memory i think it was
uh
it was uh it was definitely single moms
women that were always fighting with
their exes over
their kids or money so loads and loads
of conflict
um another one that popped up long
before i even you know knew what the red
pill was was daddy issues like women
just
didn't have a good relationship with her
father and i learned real quick to stay
away for women like that
see it's interesting because
like to me that's almost
like comment share
when it's over the subscribe right so
if i wasn't saying anything that was on
point they wouldn't get upset that's the
only time people get upset
right
right
um
so
what is like so would you categorize
most of your advice now like like
is it like young men watching watching
at all
uh mostly men it's probably about
90 92 percent men or so there's a few
women that watch my stuff
and um it's mostly
25 to 35 40 year old guys
okay say average age is around early 30s
and would you consider yourself red pill
is that like because i know there's a
couple different there's like blue pill
red pill white tail
uh
yeah
i think that term has been hijacked by a
bunch of people and rebranded for their
own purposes in ways that i
never saw coming because to me all it
all it meant to me when i
um
started to read about stuff like this
starting with rolos books was
just unplugging from lies which is why i
titled my book the unplugged alpha right
um
it it feels like there's all these
cliques
it's kind of like high school it's like
going back to high school like oh i'm a
this pill or i'm at that pillar you're
wrong because of this reason it's like
everybody just wants to
sort of scrap with you because they
think that their club's the best one but
um you can call it whatever you want my
view and estimation of the sorts of
conversations that i have is really
as as guys you're fed a lot of
comforting lies throughout your life
that don't really serve you
and
the talks that i have have are about
unplugging from those lies so
my preferred way about going about it is
calling it the unplugged
um and what would you say are like the
big slides that are told to young men
oh
how much time you got
we could start with you know just just
be yourself you know that's a great one
just just be yourself son and the right
woman will come along at some point i
can't tell you the amount of guys that
took that one hook line and sinker um
you know in their youth and they
discovered as an adult that women don't
respond to that at all and they get
terrible results subscribing to that
belief
oh
wait why is that that advice
no i'm serious like i mean
yeah i was going to say like women don't
seem to understand that because
you just have to you know get up you
know brush your hair put on some clothes
and a bra and some underwear and some
shoes and you look good for the most
part but guys can't do that we don't
have that luxury
um we have a what's called the burden of
performance and we really have to do
work to be attractive to women um
men compete and women choose it's always
been that way throughout history
right
well i mean i can totally see like being
the best version of yourself but don't
you think like being authentic
that's
important and important i absolutely
agree um
there is
there is a bunch of guys that will just
fake it
you know they'll uh
i think that the pickup artist community
gets heat for this the most where they
are taught to just memorize lines or
uh peacock you know put on you know
paint their fingernails black and put on
certain outfits that you know
sensationalize you know who they are and
what they look like
um but yeah it's it's uh you know it's
multi-faceted i mean there's a lot a lot
of pieces to this puzzle
okay
yeah fair enough um
so the topic today is i was hoping we
could talk about
um what advice you would give
to young men and young women
when it comes to
day-to-day
so i think first you need to start with
a question what's your goal
okay
because the advice you would get would
depend on your goal
okay let's say their goal
is to have a family
and are we talking about men or women
um could you do both
sure
um
so for women i mean we'll start with
your side of the story
um the the most important thing if you
want to have a family and you want to be
pair bonded for a long period of time
like i'm assuming from the conventional
sense right like you don't want to have
a family and get divorced take half of
[ __ ] and run off like you're talking
about conventional family yeah yeah okay
so
for that you want to have a very low
notch count a lot of studies have
reflected and it's and it's all
confirmed from multiple different
sources that the more sexual partners a
woman has and the younger to which she
loses her virginity the less likely she
is to be able to form a healthy pair
bond to a guy
so she's
gone through
the carousel for
50 100 150 guys during her youth her 20s
or 30s or something like that she's a
really bad prospect for forming a family
so the most important thing for women
really is like women are viewed by men
as beauty objects sex objects as warren
farrell would call it but men are viewed
by women as success objects so
there's two different stories that you
have to men and women and sometimes that
drives people nuts especially people
that think that men and women are
exactly the same
but women have to preserve their value
men need to create their value
150 jesus um
um
yeah because i noticed in one of the
videos you had that you said there's no
such thing as good girls
what did you mean by that
well in today's world there's really no
such thing as good girls because they're
just bad girls that haven't been caught
yet
that's really what that means
okay um so does that mean there's like
no marriage in there
sure did it just pop up now
i've got nothing in mind it sounds good
here oh dude they're telling me in the
comments that it's echoing
so i'm just gonna
try to go really really hold on
let me
set too
you're entering the broadcast studio
okay i'm gonna remove
[Music]
okay hopefully this works a little
better um okay so are you saying that
like
you're just saying it's like more rare
to find a good game
because i just i just i think people
think my channel is
because i grew up like like in the
church so i finally find like
like a lot of those crazy stories i
don't know
okay yeah there's there's uh
there's women out there that don't have
a large notch count but again it's it's
just the bigger the notch count the
lower the probability that you have of
forming a healthy pair bond to a guy
so
again like a woman that lost her
virginity at 20 and has been in one
long-term relationship in her 20s
and let's say i meet her when she's 29
she's a better prospect than a chick
that lost her virginity at 15
and has ran through a hundred guys
okay
yeah fair enough
unfortunately the latter is quite a bit
more common than the former right
yeah yeah
um and what advice do you have for a
younger match
again so we have to define what the
objective is so the objective is the
same is have a family
[Music]
well the most important thing for men i
think if that's the case
they need to create the value you know
for themselves which is mostly built
around
what they look like so the optics of
masculinity and strength they've got
competency skills they can solve
problems
and also you're probably familiar with
the term hypergamy because it seems like
you watch some of the stuff so they have
to be successful right they have to be
able to
make it rain if you will you know they
have to know how to make money
i think beyond that though it's really
really important that men today
understand women and female nature so
that if they are going to expose
themselves to the risk of forming a
family unit in north america they take
other things into consideration they
really understand what
unplugging is and what the red pill
really means
um so
would you recommend for guys
yeah i would say that's probably
reasonable advice um somewhere between
30 to 35. i wouldn't say leave it too
late because you don't want to be an old
dad because you're going to be tired of
[ __ ]
and you don't want to do it in your 20s
because you really don't know what
you're doing in your 20s to be honest
with you
okay
um that was interesting because mike and
i have been coming on very very early
twenties but when i when i told me that
it made it again
right but that's advice that he's given
from the perspective as a guy he can't
possibly understand what's
in it for women given that advice
but
at the end of the day you know the most
important thing for women to understand
is they is they really need to preserve
their value like women are very
concerned with a man's future like when
they meet a guy and they entertain the
concept of forming a family unit she
wants to have children with him that
sort of thing she's mostly concerned
with what is this guy going to be like
in the future can he preside can he
protect does he have the financial
resources and you know the strength to
you know be a father sort of thing and
men are more concerned with her past
right so i mean again there's another
big difference between men and women
right well and i
understand
i can tell you why it's because most of
them have been led to believe their
entire life that promiscuity is okay and
that banging up you know a whole bunch
of guys is totally normal and you know
why wouldn't they believe that because
you know this toxic version of feminism
has has lied to women as as much as men
have been lied to where women now
believe that
it's it's normal and it's okay to be
promiscuous and to you know act without
consequences and they don't really have
very many consequences to be honest with
you for their behavior because there's a
lot of guys that are willing to look
past that too
right right that's not like i think i
think in today's
um
yeah it doesn't but it but it goes
against the narrative that women get
you know from society marketing social
media their friends toxic feminism you
know you can go right hollywood music
you know like everything in in culture
today encourages women to
go against you know the basic narrative
right
right right
um they're still saying they hear that
i don't hear anything on my own it
sounds
fine got a bit of an echo coming from
you but it's nothing that's brutal
yeah they are they are saying that the
echo on my mind
let me see if i can
grab wrap
why don't we try this um
let me see if i'm getting a feedback
loop on my end so
i'll mute myself when you're talking and
see if that solves a problem all right
okay okay and then we'll just flip back
and forth so go ahead and ask your next
question next question
okay
oh my gosh that actually made it way
better so i can hear it too
okay sorry
it's grabbing the headphones okay um
okay dude what
what do you think makes a woman wife
material and a man husband material
okay well if you're talking about
wife material as in the mother of
children specifically
yeah
okay so wife material for women is is is
pretty straightforward right i mean
if you're gonna deal with a
conventionally masculine guy that's
unplugged you know aka red pill
then she's gotta enter his frame she's
she's gonna have to defer to his lead um
she's certainly gonna wanna look up to a
guy that she sees as a giant like her
hypergamous best because
with the way society is today and the
social narratives one of the big
complaints that i hear from a lot of
guys from all the different spaces and
all the different pill colors and all
that sort of stuff
is women aren't marriageable because of
filipino you know the blanks it'll be
things like social media
um
unlimited unrestricted promiscuity blah
blah blah blah and all this sort of
thing so
for women to you know realistically be
marriage material in that frame she's
really got to be a feminine woman you
know conventionally feminine none of
this boss girl [ __ ] none of this you
know chasing a career and putting your
kids in daycare she's the kind of chick
that needs to say look you know i dig
your vibe you're absolutely the best
that i can do maybe you're not perfect
but i know that i can't do better
whether she says it or thinks in her
head doesn't matter but um
you know there's that component and then
you know she's going to have to want to
be a mom and want to have to raise the
kids because one of the big problems
today is a lot of these um
you know moms will go chase a career
then they'll go and uh
pop out a baby or two stick them in a
daycare center which is one of the worst
things that you can do to children today
and then hope that things just like pan
out you know good for the long term so
those would be the main things to look
at i'll just pause myself sorry just
mute myself go ahead
um yeah no i definitely agree i think
like there's definitely a shortage of
like feminine women and just like girls
that aren't
um you know like that actually even like
wanting to have kids like
like talking to girls like i i get
surprised at how many girls when they're
not even sure they want to have kids
um so i think a lot of times like girls
get offended by this because they take
that as like
they shouldn't have any ambition or
goals but i don't think that's like
necessarily like what guys are saying i
think it's just like you have to want to
be a mom like first would you agree with
that or disagree
well
there's no point in in living in a way
that the government is going to view as
a marriage so whether you're married or
not whether your common law or whatever
it is you want to call it there's no
point in doing that from a guy's
perspective unless you're going to have
kids
it's it's a pointless exercise otherwise
yeah okay um
fair enough uh what do you see as the
future of dating do you think it'll be
shifted like more towards traditional
values
or do you think that hypergamy will get
more and more out of control
um
so there's two different questions there
so we'll deal with the hypergamy thing
and the
traditional values things separately
um
no i don't see
women returning to traditional values at
all
the trend has been that women are moving
away from traditional values over the
last few decades
so i don't see a reversal on that it's
going to continue in that direction
the
hypergamy out of control narrative
is usually coming from a corner of the
web where guys have been conditioned to
believe that they should just be good
enough for being who they are
okay um i had a guy earlier this week
when i was doing my unplugged alpha show
on my channel on monday night
uh i think it was a super chat or
something he said something like you
know we have to get rid of su of social
media and you know screens and devices
uh because hypergamy's out of control so
that's usually the origin of that
hypergamy's out of control
that's
that's just magnifying what
hypergamy likes to do it's it's it's
what it's attracted to
okay and all that that social media
stuff like the screens and the tick
tocks and the snapchats and
the only fans and the instagrams and all
that does is it just magnifies
women's hypergamous nature you take that
away you take away cell phones you take
away all these apps
and you destroy them or you you know you
go back in a time machine 50 years
hypergamy still existed women still
chose the best guy that they could get
that might have been a guy from
you know uh the church might have been a
guy from a social group from family
network from the lake house you know
whoever was around there it you know it
could have been any number of those
places so it's not like you know
stripping women of these things that
make them out of control i'm doing that
like quote unquote with my fingers right
now is going to change anything women
are still hypergamous and it's a feature
not a bug of women if women were not
hypergamous
your ancestors my ancestors we would not
exist today okay the only reason why we
exist today is because
our our grandmother's great grandmothers
and so on all the way down the lineage
down you know 10 20 000 years ago all
decided to choose the best male that
they could pair bond with
do you think that men are hypergamous
too um
just because the reason i think that
sometimes is a lot of times like you see
guys that like get the option to like
upgrade so to speak with like a younger
model like you see some do that would
you say that men are hypergamous too or
no
no that's um
that's another myth um
when men trade i mean let's just call it
trading up to a younger hotter model
younger newer hotter model that's like
that's that's usually the the main
reason why guys
end relationships or get divorced is
because they have options to exercise
with younger hotter models
that's not hypergamy hypergamy is is
marrying up to a higher socioeconomic
class
you know that's all that means men are
not hyper
men will bang anything pretty much you
know as long as she's good looking
right it doesn't really matter to them
so men are not hypergamous at all
okay so so
sorry i'm just trying to understand that
so you're saying like hypergamy just
means like it has to be a socioeconomic
class and that's why like men aren't
hypergamous
yeah so it's it's dating across and up
so
if
i'm a i don't know let's say a hundred
thousand dollar a year junior lawyer
and i have the ability to earn quarter
million dollar years you know in the
next five years or something like that
and my fiance my girlfriend whoever's on
dating you know for example and and
she's entertaining me as a prospect on a
long-term basis to
you know to be the father of the kids
you know sort of thing
she's evaluate evaluating me from the
perspective of is this guy the best that
i can do like that's really all that
hypergamy means is is this guy the best
provisioning male that i can do men
never look at women and go is this the
best provisioning women that i can do
men look at women and go she's got a
nice rack and a you know a caboose let's
let's hook up like that's really what
guys are looking at they're looking at
women for their beauty women are looking
at men for their success only women are
hypergamous
okay yes i guess when i was asking that
question i just meant like trade up in
terms of like looks
um when given the option
but i guess like if hype with the
definition of hypergamy has to be
socioeconomic that wouldn't really make
sense as a question
okay um
so a piece of advice that i really liked
that you gave was um asking a girl to do
small things for you or pay for small
things and see how she responds
i think like a lot of guys get into the
trap of like dating a girl that's just
using them for their like money or their
resources
um and i think if a girl isn't willing
to like pay for a coffee every now and
then or like a bottle of wine like
that's probably like a selfish
like a girl that doesn't really care
about anyone other than herself
um so i really liked that piece of
advice that you gave
is that like something that you came
across like personally like did you have
to learn that lesson the hard way or was
that more of like an observation
yeah i've i mean i've um i've been
walking this earth a lot longer than you
and many of the guys that watch my
channel so i'll say this i mean
um
you want to test a woman to make sure
that
um
she's in your frame and that she's
willing to compliment your life so i
mean i think the video that you're
talking about was probably the one where
i was uh suggesting look if you guys you
know if you have a girl coming over
for a date you're several dates in you
know you've been seeing her more than
once obviously
um you know throw a little test at her
and say hey you know do me a favor
um i got dinner sorted out swing by the
liquor store and grab a bottle of this
wine you know on your way over or it's
really hot out you know for me like i
like score mcflurries from mcdonald's
it's like my one you know vice right i
try to stay away from sweets and crap
like that for the most part but i might
say hey look you know do me a favor on
your way over grab me a nice score
mcflurry and if she protests if she
gives you a hard time about i ain't
gonna do nothing like that for no man
you know some of this nonsense
and that's a pretty good sign that you
don't want to spend too much time with
this check on a long-term basis you keep
her at arm's length length and she might
just be a plate if that's what it is
that you want to do but you certainly
don't want to invite a woman in your
life if she can't comply with something
basic like that because when it comes to
other things later on down the road and
she's going to protest or push back or i
don't need no man for you know like none
of that nonsense it's really just a test
you know how when i talk about women
kind of [ __ ] test men a bit this is you
know this is a bit of a test to make
sure that she's compliant and that she's
in your frame that's all that really is
can you define a [ __ ] test for me like i
don't i don't actually even know what
that is
that's a good question so
it's really just a competency test um
you'll see it all the time once you
understand what it you know what it is
it's like uh
i mean if a guy can't change a tire for
example in a car and there's a flat tire
and she starts chirping on him because
they're stuck at the side of the road
and he doesn't know how to put the jack
together to jack up the car and you know
flip it out she's going to start
chirping on him and grinding his gears
about it and that's a bit of a [ __ ] test
um she wants to know that she's with a
competent guy that can do things and
that can be any number of things so
when when women
basically
do this to a guy and they'll do it less
and less once they realize that he is
the hypergamous best option for her
right like she's not going to [ __ ] test
them that much after that point or after
that points realized in her head but
it's it's just her natural innate
interest in making sure this guy isn't a
fraud basically
i'm like trying to think if i've ever
done that oh [ __ ] i guarantee you have i
guarantee you
i'm like trying to think um
okay um i also thought a good piece of
advice that you have um because what i
liked about your channel is you actually
offer some solutions um where a lot of
like redtail channels are just like you
know women are the worst don't date walk
away um you know unless you're tagged
it's over for you
well those are the black pill guys those
aren't those aren't my friends
um but one piece of advice that you used
was finding women like through common
interests as opposed to like going out
to a bar or a club
um i thought that was a really good
piece of advice because like
you know clearly
the type of girl that's gonna like that
that her hobby is drinking like that's
not gonna be a girl that like puts other
things
you know like what what skills does that
bring you like what like how does that
make you a wife or like a good mother
just going to the bars and like clubbing
every weekend
yeah right so that's one of the
complaints a lot of guys make about
women is they're not particularly keen
on the
quality of what they might uh meet in a
social venue like a nightclub or a bar
and
guys are always like well you know how
do i find a good girl sort of thing like
well first of all understand there's you
know stop stop looking for the unicorns
because they generally don't exist so
let's just set that aside for a minute
but just do what you like you know like
if you like driving fast cars join an
exotic car club there's not going to be
a lot of women there but guess what when
you trip across them at certain events
they're pretty much stunners and they
want to be there because they want to be
around top shelf men that have chased
excellence put a dent in the universe
and on our
like some kind of purpose they like
being around people like that so you're
not going to have you know the same
number of women to approach and talk to
at a club like that but they will show
up from time to time and they're a
better fit for you and your interests
with what you're doing because they're
already in that frame now it's just okay
is she going to enter my frame and
compliment my life if that's what
they're looking to do
um
no and i think that's why like i don't
really have a lot of friends with like
those crazy stories that you see on like
fresh and fit and like those different
platforms it's because like most of my
friends i
met through athletics so like i was a
three sport college athlete so that's
like where i found most of my friends
um and so like on the weekends like a
lot of my friends are going
like to a volleyball game or like
basketball like whatever it is
yeah right and and those like girls you
see on shows like that they're not
i mean
they're kind of doing a bit of a
disservice because it's like they get
these girls drunk and they get these
women with you know with bad attitudes
and they put them up there and they're
like okay let's make an example that's
that's not all women i mean that's how
many women can and do behave but there
are women out there that don't act like
that right
yeah and i actually like after fresh and
fit i started dming or like messaging
like the pr like the most attractive
girls that were on like sports teams of
mine so mine over the years
and just asking them has a guy ever like
offered to fly you out and i literally
could not find one person i'm not saying
it doesn't exist but like
um i think sometimes like the disservice
like the manosphere kind of does is they
don't really
like offer the perspective from just
like average people that don't live this
like crazy life
you probably haven't watched enough of
my videos to realize that i call it the
mantle swamp there's a reason why i call
it the manual swap
um okay another good piece of advice i
thought you had was don't date single
mothers um i think that's just common
sense
um i don't know like why girls get
defensive um anyone that has a brother
if like
like i have five brothers so i would
never tell them to pick a single mother
over a girl who didn't have kids i think
that's just common sense
yeah there's really nothing to debate
there i mean
i know lots of women that that have
younger siblings that you know that are
men and they're
really pissed off that they get
entangled with these single mommies
sometimes
they get sucked down this like vortex of
a nightmare life that they that they
have a hard time getting out of and guys
are bred to believe that they should
behave like captain sabaho and they
swoop in to protect the honor of milady
and you know it doesn't matter that i'm
not the dad but i'm the dad that stepped
up you know like you see like you see
and hear all these narratives and
it's one of the worst things that guys
can do is to
surrender
you know themselves to a single mommy
and raise the offspring of some other
dude or in some cases she's got
three kids in tow from three different
men
guys that do that do it because they're
low-hanging fruit and it's easier than
doing the work on themselves
making something out of themselves and
being on a purpose right like they would
have a lot more options if they did that
and and hey listen you know like i'm
speaking from experience too like i've
dated single mommies like i got into an
ltr with a single mommy for a few years
it's about the dumbest thing i ever did
in my life
um what do you think about like girls
dating a guy with kids do you feel the
same way like if you had a daughter
would you tell her to avoid guys with
well it's a different story you know
again so there's a lot of okay well men
and women are the same so let's talk
about the differences between single
mommies and single daddies some of the
big differences are when
a woman is a parent
she often has custody of the kids about
80 percent of the time so if you're a
single guy dating a single mommy you're
probably going to end up spending more
time with that guy's kids than what he
does okay so that's one big difference
another big difference is women
parentally invest into children for nine
months in their bodies they birth them
and then they have to raise them right
men don't need to do that there's a big
difference in the state of my body
versus a woman's body after she's had
three kids and let's say that i'm a
single dad with three kids there's a big
difference between the state of me and
her
another big difference is men generally
speaking choose careers that pay a lot
more money
right so i'm going to be making a lot
more money than what most single mommies
make right so there's a lot of big
differences i mean you can't say
well if you tell guys not to date single
mommies then you should tell you know
girls not to date single fathers well
one of the interesting things about
single fathers is
something called pre-selection and
if you've got a kid good-looking kid you
know you pair bonded with a nice-looking
woman you made a nice child you've got
priest selection that actually looks
favorable to quite a few women
so it's not it's not the detriment that
a lot of guys think that it can be
um
yeah no i definitely agree like i've
actually dated guys with kids before
like it's like that's fine for me but my
dad actually like really did not like
that i was dating a guy with kids
um
so i was just curious if you
like
yeah and i can tell you why so so men
are inherently disgusted by the idea of
parentally investing in somebody else's
child
right so if the child's not theirs
they're inherently disgusted like it's a
feature of of men they want to know that
the child that they're investing their
time effort and resources in is actually
theirs and there's an roi on it right
oh that makes a lot of sense actually i
never thought about it that way well
especially like my dad guy who he is
so one of the other things that i was
going to say is that like women know
with a hundred percent assurance that a
child is theirs because they birth it
right even even men in a marriage
because i mean the rate of cuckoldry is
somewhere between 10 and 30 we don't
know what it is because it relies on
deception but let's say it's on the low
end
there's there's a number of guys out
there that have parentally invested in
children that they thought were theirs
that they later discover aren't theirs
right men don't have assurance in
paternity right women do 100 so that's
why men you know have that level of
disgust when it comes to getting
involved with somebody else's kid that's
not theirs that's why your dad in fact
probably felt that way about you
yeah no that's interesting so do you
like for do you have a daughter
yep i've got a kid
um and would you tell her like that
doesn't matter if he has a kid like
knowing what you know or what like does
that disgust you too
well there's a whole bunch of different
conversations that i'd have with my own
child and i'm not going to talk about
those publicly um that's something that
i keep private to myself
okay yeah fair enough um
okay could you please explain this i
hear this all the time in the manosphere
and it's she is not yours it's just your
turn like what is that
that's like so negative to me and i
guess like because my parents have been
married for so long i'm like
it kind of like makes me feel like weird
i guess
um like why do you think that's such a
common phrase is it because divorces are
mostly initiated by women
um
i think it's more of a coping sort of
mechanism i think that guys tell bros
that it's like hey bro don't worry she's
not yours it's just your turn sort of
thing because they don't know how to
dive into the uh
evolutionary psychology component of
attraction and why men and women make
the choices that they do so it's
convenient it makes people feel better
um it's not that it's inaccurate i mean
it's just it's just a different way of
of like phrasing something else that
could be distilled differently but
um people get if again when when
somebody gets offended by a sound bite
or a catch phrase it's usually because
it resonates with them and it gets under
their skin right
does it get no i just
it doesn't really resonate with me like
it just it isn't really what i've seen
like
with my parents so i guess that's why i
don't like it because i'm like
it's it's
you know it's just an interesting way of
of kind of saying well
you know women aren't that monogamous
you know like you could say she's not
yours it's just your turn or you could
say well women aren't particularly good
at monogamy right or you know there's
different ways that you could rephrase
it and it would mean the same thing it's
just it just happens to be that that's
the sound bite that resonates the most
okay fair enough um
another thing that it says you
are probably not her first choice
um
i
i have a little bit of a like isn't
everyone someone's second choice
like i mean like this is the way i think
about it right
if you have like a supermodel and like
an average girl and he picks that out
like i feel like most guys would pick
the supermodel if given like both
choices you know
um i can tell you where that came from
yeah that came from a chris rock stand
up i think it was either chris rock or
chris tucker i think it was rock and he
said something like you know to the
audience he's like hey guys you know the
number one reason why your girl is
pissed off at you today because he's
kind of like working up to it is you
weren't her first choice and it's like
the audience audience you know bursts up
in the laughter that's where that came
from and
the reason why they burst into laughter
is because for the most part when women
get into a marriage with a guy and it's
mostly you know long-term relationships
and couples when they're responding to
that question
women don't generally settle for their
first choice um we talked off air before
we started you brought up the term alpha
widow right so most women have been
alpha widowed at some point in their
life meaning the guy that they pined for
that they were hoping to lock down
didn't commit and walked so that's why
you know that you know you're not her
first choice joke you know tends to
resonate and you know everybody gets
such a kick out of it
yeah no i've definitely seen like the
alpha widow thing um
i guess like i feel like girls like get
over it eventually at some point
um
but no i guess i could kind of see
where that comes from a little bit
i just
i was just thinking about it the other
day and i was just like i feel like
everyone is someone's second choice like
at some point
you're not getting about the same for
guys guys yeah it's you know it's the
same for both sexes it's like you know
guys don't usually get the girl that
they want and women don't generally get
the guy that they want on a long-term
basis i mean it's it's it's kind of
across the board that's that's probably
one of the few things that are across
the board actually
okay um someone in the comments wants to
know
um
this is a black pill question ask him
why he thinks money is important if
looks are clearly the number one factor
well i'm not going to respond to black
pillars because they just try to bait
you with nonsense that's that's
absolutely absurd go watch my channel
read my book you'll get the answer
okay fair enough
see let me just talk about that for a
minute because these guys get so hung up
on looks okay
that's all they focus on oh if you're
not a chad you're screwed just don't do
anything bro it's a waste of time but
all they'll do is sit around all day
talking about women right they hate
women they can't get them or they say
they can't get them and all they do is
talk about them and they get mad at guys
that get them like me right now
so for perspective
you've seen my videos uh i'm about six
foot two 210 pounds i'm bald i have to
wear glasses to read [ __ ] because my
eyesight sucks i got third degree burns
all over my upper body my arms you know
blah blah blah can go down the list i'm
not perfect
i don't have a problem with women
why because i've done the work
um no well that's the thing about
blackpill is like i think there's some
truth into what they're saying like
especially with height for men like
like i'm six foot but i know that's not
true no no no no i'm gonna squash that
because i had a roommate for about eight
years who was five foot five and he was
a slayer
okay
height matters yeah women want
height
they definitely seek that when it comes
to
uh getting the best genes
but there's lots of guys that are sub
six foot that do very very well with
women because they max out in other
areas right if you're short if you're
five foot five
be short jacked and rich with good game
okay you know you control what you can't
and you walk away from what you can't
that's that's the problem that a lot of
these doomers have is they get too
focused on
oh you're screwed bud there's nothing
you can do man
no i was i was about to say like i think
there's some truth to it but at the end
of the day like what else are you
supposed to do you can like sit there
wallowing in it or you can like do the
best with what you got which i think is
like
the best solution for anybody you know
like i could i could sit here crying and
saying like oh like a victorious secret
model would have more options than me
but like
you know like who what how does that
help me you know
um but i agree with you like i think
girls just want someone taller than them
so like if you're five five like there's
a bunch of like five
foot to five five girls
that like would have a problem i can i
can destroy that narrative of all that
women care about is looks like there's a
lot of really messed up
short guys
even deformed guys
okay that have done great with women um
you can look up after this show sean
stevenson on my channel i did an
interview with him i think it's on the
plane to win cast there's a couple
months before he died
go watch that video with the interview
you can see exactly what he looks like
and you can see why he managed to land a
good-looking girl and marry her
right it's not all about looks do looks
matter absolutely they matter of course
they matter women select guys based on
you know what they look like because
they want the sexy sons you know lots of
research has been done on this
is it all that matters
no that's where they get it wrong
right no i definitely agree i actually
went to um
a pickup conference this weekend like
pua or whatever oh no you didn't
which one
i'm nosy so i just like i like to know
things um it was without john anthony
lifestyle
oh well there's your first mistake right
there
um and it was actually really
interesting to like
like even talk to guys that like sleep
with all of these girls and like talk
about what they want and like a wife and
even the guys that sleep with like the
most like
absurds of a certain amount of girls
like they still want a girl like that
doesn't hasn't slept with a lot of guys
there's you know what i'm just gonna set
that aside because there's a lot of
[ __ ] that comes out of that that
area of the internet that's all been
dispelled you guys can go look it up if
you search for the right names and
exposed it'll certainly come up
okay yeah i don't know
it was
it was interesting to be honest like
that was a very you'll see i'm gonna
have a video on it in a couple like
probably a week or two it was
yeah that's a different side of the
internet that i did not know
um okay let's see what other questions
do you think there is a shortage of
husbands or a shortage of wives right
now in the dating market market
i'd say both because women have
incredibly high expectations of men
and
there's there's very few men that can
tick off those boxes for women
right um you know women like women are
the gatekeepers to sex like they decide
when intimacy happens men are the
gatekeepers to relationships so
uh there's there's a few
sorry
there's a good number of top shelf men
out there that um you know could take on
a wife or you know multiple women in
their lives and some of them do you know
some of their married was a mistress
some are just monogamously married some
are in open marriages a lot of top shelf
guys out there
um connect can basically exercise these
options because of who they are and what
they've done in life uh that being said
there's loads of beautiful women out
there there's there's probably more
attractive women than what there are top
shelf men
so
i'll frame it that way because that's
what men look for they look for beauty
right beyond that you know if you're
talking about pair bonding on a
long-term basis they have to have you
know cues of femininity they have to
basically you know be able to enter his
frame complement his life all that stuff
long list of stuff that we could talk
about some other time but yeah there's
there's um
there's a problem
the the the fabric of society has been
torn apart
over this last century and some would
argue you know for the most part
terribly over the last few decades but
it's it's very very difficult for men
and women to form these types of healthy
long-term relationships because of the
state of things right now
um can you talk a little bit about um
true marketplace value that was
something that you said in
one of your videos
do you mean sexual marketplace value
yes yeah okay so smv is a
term i think rollo may have coined i'm
not sure if it came from somewhere else
but all that really means is like what's
your value to women you know to the
opposite sex
and women are evaluating you based on
looks your ability you know to create
resources you know
money basically is what that means
looks money well the way that the red
pill you know sums it up is looks money
game status basically right guys that
tick off all of those boxes and are in
high in all of those areas will be
highest on the sexual market value scale
and when roller frames that he's
basically saying look guys peak in their
mid to late 30s women peak around 23.
so we're on different places on the smv
scale um he's got it on a blog somewhere
on his uh website so you can look that
up there's an entire blog on sexual
marketplace value if you want to check
it out
um i actually don't this is one thing i
think i disagree with um with the
manosphere i i do agree like i think
that girls
smv
like that makes sense around 23. if if
anything like i would even say a little
younger
um
but for men like i don't think the
majority of men keep themselves in good
enough shape to like peak in their mid
30s
uh you may not be tripping across these
dudes then maybe they're not coming
across your circle i don't know what you
do for a living where you're going right
all i see is a little picture of your
head right now so i'm not sure what what
access you have to these top shelf men
but there's lots of guys out there that
have got their [ __ ] together i got a lot
of them in my community right like we
have a lot of conversations on a regular
basis they're on my business here
they're entrepreneurs like these guys
are not [ __ ] around on apps like tick
tock and instagram and stuff like that
they're busy putting a dent in the
universe so you have to understand like
they're not as obvious as you think they
would be right
no that's why i said the majority of men
like what percent of men are really like
putting themselves in a position to be
high value i would say like not the
majority
um what i was thinking is like most of
the guys i went to college with like i
most of them like don't look better now
than they did like in college
you should get out there more
okay um what do you think of prenups do
you like do you think that prenups like
work in general like would you recommend
to guys to get married or do you think
it's too much of a risk
um so what time is it here i got about
another uh 10 minutes you're good with
that
good okay um so when it comes to prenups
i think i think what you need to do is
you need to broaden the conversation to
managing risk prenups are one part of
managing risk like
i'm a top shelf guy i got lots of money
i got fast cars i got multiple
businesses blah blah blah
if i'm going to invite a woman into my
life like let's say that i'm i'm saying
to myself okay i think i'd like to
father a few more children
um i need a
feminine beauty to sort of enter my
frame and compliment me with that one of
the things that she would have to do is
sign a prenup it's not it's it's very
like the probability of me finding a
check that's on the same financial level
that i am is going to be very very low
so
the concept of a prenup needs to be
discussed if that's something that
you're going to do
another thing that you definitely want
to consider when it comes to managing
risk and we don't have a ton of time to
go through all of them but
i did a video i think this week it's
uploaded on my channel within the last
few days
and i go through the specific states
that are father friendly because one of
the things you got to understand is like
okay well if you're going to have kids
you're living in the west you know if
you're living in the u.s or canada or
something like that you're going to be
in an environment where half the time
marriages are going to end
right okay well you wouldn't jump out of
a freaking plane without a parachute on
you know just hoping for the best so you
have to take some precautionary steps
and one of the things i'd recommend guys
should do is entertain living in a state
that isn't going to make it hard for him
to parent his child or his children if
things don't work out
so it's so it's a broader question than
just prenups it's a question of how do
you manage risk when you're parenting or
fathering children
um
do you think like
that girls should be open to signing
prenups
look if they don't want to sign it then
it's a flat out no that's that's the
angle that men need to understand that
they have to take it's not like oh well
if you don't want to do it then that's
fine sweetheart we'll just set that
aside and that's okay and i'll put my
entire fortune on the table at risk in
case you decide to change your mind
later
that's what an idiot would say and you
know if if if that's his choice you know
if he says himself okay then we'll just
set this aside hey
don't don't get pissed off if you lose
half your [ __ ] and don't get to see your
kids because you don't take some
precautionary steps if the knot happens
to untie
frankly i don't care what women think
it's something to protect and preserve
my wealth that i've worked for and i'm
not going to have the government or the
state take half of them away because
they feel like it or because a woman
decides to change her mind about how she
feels about the relationship at a later
date
no i definitely agree with you like i
like personally wouldn't have a problem
signing a prenup um
i think sometimes girls see it as like
like i think sometimes girls are a
little bit more emotional than logical
so sometimes they see it as like i think
this marriage is gonna fail um
but like i don't know i personally would
wanna pray it up
so i don't i don't really
think like if a girl especially wants to
be married to a guy with a lot of money
like that should be something that you
sign
100
okay um
okay i'm gonna ask you one more question
what qualities should one look for in
a
in a husband
so sorry you're asking that from your
perspective as a woman
yeah like um
well
the advice i'd give a woman that wants
to get into a marriage is
preserve your value that is the most
important thing
don't be a hoe basically don't go out
there and be promiscuous with a bunch of
guys don't go seeking attention on
social media apps when you're in a
long-term relationship
you know be a woman of value preserve
your value have some dignity about what
about what your worth is on a sexual
marketplace women and men are totally
different and
the biggest red pill that women need to
take that they really struggle with
is they approach life today from the
perspective that men and women are the
same you know we're all equal so you
know if men can do this then i can do it
too sort of thing and that's a big fat
lie that women need to unplug from
for
your female listeners if you have any i
think you said most your listeners are
male but if there's any women listening
to this if you want to hear this
perspective from a woman's angle
go follow suzanne banker i think is her
name i believe if i'm not mistaken she
just wrote a book actually for women
that are marriage minded
suzanne banker you said let me write
that down
yeah she's got a youtube channel too i
bet if you contact her she'll probably
do an interview with you too
okay
yeah i don't
i feel like girls
make it so much harder than it has to be
i think dating as a girl doesn't have to
be that hard
like be fit stay in shape be feminine be
friendly
don't sleep with too many guys it's not
like a crazy ask that guys are like
demanding
yeah it's it doesn't seem that
complicated to to me anyway but
um hey you know when you
listen to the way that women respond to
that sort of stuff
most of them lose their ever-loving
minds over it
yeah well i mean i think usually you can
tell like
how a girl reacts to that type of thing
like
what she's done because the girls tend
to get mad over like what part of that
doesn't like fit them you know
right like what did i say earlier like a
bomber only gets flak when it's over the
target right
okay well do you want to share with my
listeners like where they can find you
i'm sure a lot of them already know who
i am just entrepreneurs and cars on
youtube if you want to really unplug and
go a little bit deeper on some of the
stuff that we kind of talked about today
my books on amazon the unplugged alpha
kindle print and audible
check it out
okay thank you so much for coming on the
channel i really appreciate it um for
everyone watching do not forget to like
comment subscribe to the channel um go
subscribe to entrepreneurs and cars
while you're at it and i will talk to
you guys next time
see you later
you